we discovered the U.S governments buying
seeds and fertilizer for Ukrainian
farmers and covering the salaries of
Ukraine's First Responders all 57 000 of
them Russia's Invasion shrank Ukraine's
economy by about a third we were
surprised to find that to keep it afloat
the U.S government is subsidizing small
businesses
like Tatiana abramova's knitwear company
and our proxy war against Russia that
the Biden White House claims isn't a
proxy war at all apparently they don't
even know how much money we've already
sent to Ukraine do you have a general
figure you can give us
I'm not going to stand here and give a
precise figure
well it's more than 100 billion dollars
Jake and apparently not even a
government shutdown will stop the
funding it won't even slow it down
that's right at a time when most
Americans are struggling and really
worried millions are at risk of not
getting paid if the government does shut
down we're still making sure that the
people of Ukraine are taken care of hmm
joining me now is Kentucky Senator Rand
Paul of the Foreign Relations Committee
Senator um 60 Minutes did reporting that
you know we've been waiting for about
where this money is really going but
that's just kind of the tip of the
iceberg seeds and salaries and
apparently sweaters in Ukraine
well you know a significant chunk is
non-military a bunch of it is going to
government salaries I've also read that
it's going to government pensions and
you're right to add insult to injury if
there's a shutdown U.S government
workers will not be paid but Ukrainian
workers will be paid by the U.S taxpayer
there's nothing in the Constitution that
allows for spending like this to another
country the spending clause in our
constitution says that Congress can
spend according to its enumerated powers
the power is given to it by the
Constitution and also for the general
welfare so it's illegal for the U.S
government if they want to give a
hundred billion dollars to my state of
Kentucky they can't do it that would
violate the general welfare Clause what
do you think it violates to send it to
another country are Framers never
imagined in their worst nightmare that
we would send that much money overseas
but it violates every precept of the
Constitution and I'm going to do
everything I can to stop them from
sinning anymore
senator Paul we saw Mitch McConnell and
Chuck Schumer you know walking through
the Senate
um with zelenski last week and zelinski
was kind of in front of them and they
were walking they look very happy I
haven't seen McConnell look that happy
since I don't since I don't know when
um but what's happening here I mean
they're not representing
the yeah there's mcconnelly's beaming
um they're not representing the views of
certainly most Republicans and an
increasingly skeptical public about
continuing this funding of what looks
like now another Forever War
you know one of Washington's dirty
little secrets is that the high-ranking
Republicans and high-ranking Democrats
really are there's not much difference
not much difference on spending and
certainly not much difference on wanting
to give our money away or involve Us in
Foreign Wars but it is quite unpopular I
come from a fairly Republican state now
and nearly 70 percent of Kentucky
Republicans think we've got problems
here at home we had some bad flooding
last year we've had tornado damage we've
got roads that need to be fixed we can't
even get the kids to school in
Louisville it's so bad but the thing is
is we don't see why that money should be
going over to Ukraine and you know just
a couple weeks ago they fired 24 people
over there there's still no Inspector
General looking over the money they sent
a hundred billion dollars in nobody's
counting the money and nobody's looking
for the fraud and Ukraine's always been
in the top 10 or historically been in
the top ten for corruption so now I
think it's huge mistake it's it's there
it's an unpopular idea and yet the
leaders in Washington are dead set on
ramming this down our throat but I told
them I am not going along with it I will
not allow my consent to let them push
through more money for Ukraine
particularly when they have the gall to
tell us they're going to pay Ukrainian
government workers while our workers go
unpaid that is the height of gall and I
won't stand for it yeah
Senator that does take the cake or in
this case the sweater thank you very
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else